[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferris welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferris show and I'm
going to skip the Preamble I'm going to
keep it light my guest today my oh my do
we have lots to cover and I'm excited to
dig in my guest today is Sheila
this is her second appearance on the
podcast Sheila has spent the last three
decades working to understand how people
can better navigate conflict with a
particular specialty in difficult
conversations God knows we need more of
that expertise for all of our sakes she
is a founder of Triad Consulting Group a
professor at Harvard Law School and a
co-author of thanks for the feedback the
science and art of receiving feedback
well even when it's off base unfair
poorly delivered and frankly you're not
in the mood with with Douglas Stone and
difficult conversations subtitle how to
discuss what matters most also with
Douglas Stone and Bruce Patton with a
newly updated Third Edition that was
just released in August Sheila and her
colleagues at Triad work with leaders
and organizations to build their
capacity to have the conversations that
matter most her clients have included
Pixar American Express the MBA the
Singapore supreme court maybe we'll talk
about that who knows the Obama White
House and theologians struggling with
the nature of Truth and God she's
schooled in negotiation daily by her
three children you can find my first and
very popular conversation with Sheila at
tim. blog sheilah Heen Sheila nice to
see you again thanks for making the time
it's great to see you I know last time
we spoke at length I was in the midst of
a very challenging chapter in my
personal relationship
and when my team and I reviewed the last
conversation we had which I always do
before a conversation like this so went
through the entire round one and there
was a line that stood out for all of us
and it might be a paraphrase you can
feel free to fact check this but yeah
yeah oh I can't wait to hear what you're
about to say quote it's not just that we
have difficult conversations in our most
important relationships those
conversations are the
relationship and I've been thinking
about this a lot in the sense
that it seems like our most important
relationships are defined and steered in
large part by how we handle the
difficult conversations how we handle
things when we are perhaps not our best
selves and to that extent they are what
Define a good or a bad relationship so I
just wanted to share that because it's
stuck out for everyone who reviewed the
last conversation that we had on the
side of my team how should we talk about
because we did discuss a lot surrounding
difficult conversations and we will Edge
into a lot of shared territory but how
should we talk about feedback for me
when feedback is incoming part of what
I'm doing is scanning for what's wrong
with
it and we can Circle back to this
question because there's a great set of
things that are typically wrong with
feedback at least that other people give
me so it's a shift from I have to decide
whether I agree or disagree
and what's wrong with it to before I
decide let me just understand it let me
just understand what they're trying to
say so if we go to what language does
that suggest you can ask questions in
one of two directions feedback always
has a past and a future so you can
either ask more about where it's coming
from like say more about what you heard
me say or can you give me an example of
that or tell me more about the impact
that that had in the exchange so you're
asking questions of curiosity about what
is it that you notice that is prompting
you to say this to me the other
direction that you can ask questions in
is is forward-looking where is it going
to if I were to take your advice what
would I do differently What specifically
are you suggesting or
requesting if I'm feeling particularly
defensive that second set of questions
is sometimes easier if I ask the
backward looking ones it'll suck me into
an argument about why they misunderstood
or misremember or that's not really what
happened if I just go to okay if I were
to follow your
advice what would that look like in
practice MH in everyday life and
sometimes they have an instant reaction
and I realize oh you're just saying you
know
drop you a note back to say I got
it I can do that if I thought what we
were talking about am I responsive in a
you know fully human emotional way
you're just saying just let me know
where you got my note you don't have to
give me the whole answer which is of
course why maybe I'm not responding yet
because I I'm like oh gosh that's a big
question let me think about it I want to
give you I want to give you a good
response and you're just saying just let
me know you got it you can give me the
full response later so that's an example
of oh I I Now understand what you want
sometimes a person doesn't know what
they want but then that centers the
conversation on okay so I don't know how
to change if you don't know what would
tell
you that this is
better right there was freezing from the
last conversation we had that I thought
was it came up multiple times which was
help me understand dot dot dot which I
thought was very skillful because it is
basically
indirectly pointing the fingers at
yourself if that makes
sense rather than explain yourself help
me
understand implies a level of
responsibility on the receiver that
might help to diffuse things or
deescalate things if someone giving
feedback comes in hot right so the the
wording might be
diplomatic but the tone is listen
a or C yeah it's amazing how clear that
message is any thoughts for either how
to deescalate or selft talk that you can
use so that the person on the receiving
end is able to kind of
reply in a
calm cool and collected
fashion it could be that calm cool and
collected is more aspir irational than
realistic and one thing that can help is
just to name the surprise MH or the this
just came out of left field I'm totally
knocked off
my Center so just saying wow
okay uh sorry this is coming out of left
field so I'm just kind of on my back
foot so that you're just naming where
you're at in the this moment and
sometimes just naming it can help you
find your feet again because you're like
okay I've just accurately described
where I'm at I can be in that space and
now they know I'm in that space m or
just saying okay I'm feeling a little
defensive and then you can move
to a question so a question that I've
been using recently that has helped just
quickly get to the heart of what's going
on is what do you feel like I don't get
mhm what is it that you feel I really
don't get about whatever this situation
about how this impacted you whatever is
they're trying to tell you MH that they
feel like you're
really clueless
about that's often going to cut through
the noise MH so let's if we could just
jump
into a real life example and perhaps we
could
examine painful feedback from the past
and your
own well we can talk about my own but I
thought we would given given my job as
The
Inquisitor that I would ask that will
not protect you my friend I know it's
not the Flack jacket I always hope it to
be but I came into this expecting that I
would be opening the kimono per se but
you just finished the Third Edition of
difficult
conversations and you had to contend
with some reader feedback on an example
on that book that got large reactions
could you elaborate on this so there
were a lot of things that
we looked at fresh and rewrote and
reworked and you know changed about the
Third Edition and one of the examples
that got the biggest and most consistent
negative reaction from readers was an
example a story in the chapter about
shifting from blame to Joint
contribution and it's a sexual
harassment example and although it's
told as to characters all the examples
in the book are real or amalgams but but
disguised that particular example was
mine and it came from an experience that
I had pretty early in my career I was in
my
20s I was sent abroad to work on a
project International project it was
bringing together Consultants from lots
of different places and simply because
my organization was the one that was
holding the funding and and in charge of
the project in the
collaboration I got named as the team
lead and I was the youngest person on
the team by a good margin part of what
happened of course and it was we're in a
very stressful context on site in a
divided ethnic conflict so the task that
we have together we have to come
together build a set of Team
relationships that are highly functional
and adaptive in the moment as things
unfold and so the first couple of days
are really spent sorting out sort of how
do we connect and how are we going to
collaborate together as we tackle
getting ready for the project over those
first couple of days things settled down
in terms of people's reactions to me
being the team lead you know I'm sure
their first reaction was like really
because you look like you're still in
high
school so and I have several decades of
experience which was fair enough
honestly there was one guy who was
particularly hostile to the idea and
continued to be hostile to the idea so I
decide that the answer for this to win
him over and sort out whatever is going
on with his hostility
to my
leadership I'll assign us a piece of the
next day to work on together and then
we'll we'll just have to sort it out
right because we'll work on it oneon-one
so I did that and it it worked
beautifully I soon learned that it had
worked a little too well because he
started saying things
like I feel like in another world we
would have fallen in love you know he
was indic ating directly and indirectly
romantic
interest and I was completely freaked
out by
that and so I'd say oh you know I'm
married and he he said so am I what's
the problem and oddly
enough I felt totally Paralyzed by it
and I'm not a shy person I'm pretty
quick to speak up in fact that's some of
the feedback I'm getting now which is
I'm a little too quick to speak up we
can Circle back to that now I just have
the opposite problem and I felt like I'm
I'm sending the indirect signals and
slightly more direct signals that I'm
not interested and it's not
stopping and I'm trying to avoid him
Etc you know he's always like right
right there at any meal he's right next
to
me and so I felt paralyzed because I
felt like gosh I have to be sure that
I'm right about his intentions that I'm
reading him correctly maybe it's just a
cultural difference between us there was
no HR right to go
to and it wasn't a hierarchical thing
some sexual harassment situations are
really tough because you know it's in
hierarchy with a boss here I'm actually
in
charge and so the insight for me was oh
gosh I don't need to be sure I'm right
about his
intentions I just have to describe the
impact that having on me number one and
number two and the reason it's in the
contribution chapter is that it suddenly
started occurring to me that I might
have been sending mixed signals by
accident in other words I arranged for
us to do this piece of the project
together and maybe that was signaling
interest right and so if I just change
my contribution so my contribution to
the problem was maybe
inadvertently seeming like I was
reaching out to give him special
attention
because I was paying attention to what
he was doing to try to get him in our
meetings to get him engaged win him over
and the other thing I'm contributing is
I'm not saying directly that I'm not
interested so I'll change those
contributions so that was a big aha for
me we disguise it we write it into the
book the reaction that we got
was I we had one one student of ours who
told us when I got to that part I threw
the book across the
room which is not really the reader
reaction you're hoping for yeah what was
the explanation behind that if there was
one you're blaming the
victim you're blaming the victim you're
saying that she the name in the book is
Sydney that Sydney is at fault for her
own situation that she should deal with
it alone in other words she's got to
figure out what she needs to change
because she got herself into this and
people also had strong views about what
was really going on with him they had
strong views about what you should do
like you should never have this
conversation directly it's unsafe you
should go to
HR so it was a very clear set of themes
in the reaction by the way what's your
reaction as you listen
my reaction as I listen is actually more
a set of questions for instance I'm very
curious if the throw the book across the
room reaction is mostly American Born
and Raised readers of a certain vintage
yes right I'm wondering if that's
something you have observed in readers
from many other cultures I'm also
wondering many other ages because it it
strikes me as though that may be a very
contemporary
industrialized us response or North
American response to things which is
just a hypothesis but that's that's what
comes to mind from me from a curiosity
perspective totally and and what I
particularly like about your
curiosity is that like me it allows us
to locate the problem in
them it's just that you guys are
you know either and I have this reaction
totally too young like I was like you'll
get it once you're in the work world a
big reaction was like well this just
can't happen this should not happen
which I don't disagree with and it does
so the goal is what do you do about it
so some people were
upset that it was even in the book MH
because you shouldn't be talking about
these things and like well to book on
difficult conversations so we want to be
tackling the ones that actually happened
we're not going to choose the the easy
ones we're not going to choose the easy
ones and if we don't have it people say
well what about really hard situations
like sexual harassment you don't address
that so I agree with you that that
reaction was coming partly
from women
who and and it has morphed a little bit
over the years in terms of the
generational sense of what should happen
and the ideal world I think when we're
in our
20s as young adult
we come into the world with a strong
sense of the way the world should
work and then we discover that that's
not the way the world Works in many
situations and it's kind of outrageous
and then we're like why why are we not
changing this why are you guys
tolerating it and this is why
revolutions right are led by young
people and I think as as I've gotten
older what I'm noticing in myself is
that okay I address some things and
don't address others but I also figure
out how to navigate the world as it
is and then those of us in leadership
have been successful in the world as it
is and so we're like you know don't
worry about it you'll be able to
navigate it it's a lot better than when
I was your age but I think that's partly
why we get complacent because we do see
the progress that's been made but then
we can underappreciate the progress
still to be made I will also say I yeah
that I want to be fair to my to the
other readers some of whom were young
women from other cultures who have had
even more
stressful extreme
horrific experiences right and were
looking for guidance and feeling like
they were being told well you're on your
own
right what were you about to
say well I was going to just say before
we unpack some of the macro and also the
example that you're about to give which
I don't want you to lose track of unless
I missed it you didn't share how you
ultimately address the situation so I I
I feel like that's a critical piece of
the story so in the original edition
let's just
say how did you explain how you then
handled that very uncomfortable
situation part of what was so powerful
for me about realizing oh actually there
are a couple things that I have done
that have probably contributed to this
and those I have control over those I
can
change and that was a relief that was
liberating for me it was like oh okay
well I can be clear about the fact even
clear about the fact and I I don't have
to know that I'm right about his
intentions so
I pulled him aside and said hey by the
way I may not be reading you right at
all so I'm not saying this is what you
intend and you have made a number of
comments about having a romantic
relationship or a personal relationship
and and I think I probably haven't been
clear that that's not of interest to me
I'm enjoying our working relationship
and and that's
super fun and I think we're doing a a
great
job but if I've been unclear you know I
I apologize for that and that was kind
of the of it you know we only had
another week or so of work to do
together
but I felt incredibly
empowered and so therefore when later
readers are saying you're blaming the
victim and you're saying it's her fault
and that she's on her
own I felt really misunderstood because
I was like no no no we have a whole
section of that chapter that's about
like it's really important not to blame
the victim and that a victim seeing some
contribution also gives them back some
control and power sometimes it's not
saying they did anything wrong you're
not blaming them they didn't do anything
wrong and it helps them have a little
bit of control over making sure it
doesn't happen again in many cases which
was how it felt to
me so when we're getting this feedback
from
readers I lost sight of what we're
trying to do in a book which is that
we're trying to put
in stories that resonate with people
where people we think of writing as a
conversation with the reader's internal
voice and if we're doing something
that's creating a wait a minute that's
not true that's not the way it was for
me or or that's overstated if we're
we're creating a reaction it's going to
get in the way of the conversation that
we're having because a a book is a
oneway conversation so we're trying to
anticipate what readers are wondering
about or objecting to or confused by or
feel is off based and then address it
right away in the book
so the good news was that we had an
example that was generating a lot of
reader reaction that people were
bringing their own experience
to that's good but the fact that then it
tells the story as if there's one way to
handle it when this was a relatively
mild version that didn't have power
differentials in the way that many
people have
faced meant that I suddenly because it
was my example was feeling defensive and
like well you're misunderstanding
me and so we did an interim fix where we
tried to clarify there was no HR that
this wasn't the only way to handle it
the interim fix totally didn't work I
see so it wasn't clear in the original
Edition that you did not have HR or some
intermediary to go to or it wasn't
sufficiently clear yes we felt that it
was clear so that's the thing is we felt
that it was incredibly clear and that
other people were misunderstanding
us and we had a long list of all the
things that were wrong with their
reactions and understanding so we tried
to get clearer and clearer with the
example instead of it didn't work it
didn't work it didn't work at all so
what we needed to do which which was a
what we finally did was
say it's not about my
experience actually it's about what the
reader the readers are bringing to their
own life
experience and and the felt pain that
they want help with and this example the
way we're telling it is not meeting them
where they are at and is a particular
version which is not
Universal So eventually in the Third
Edition we took it out we replaced it
with a different example that got to the
points we were trying to make with it
because we realized that we're just
creating more noise than help let me ask
a question about that because this
is the situation itself is outside of my
personal experience but receiving
feedback on books yes books is in my
personal experience so very curious did
you receive strong positive
feedback on that particular example from
other readers or was it pretty
uniformly negative or confusion or did
you also
receive a equal amount or comparable
amount of positive feedback from
readers there were a couple of
people who came forward to to say oh I
actually really loved that example mhm
you know it immediately helped me see
situations where oh I I feel more
empowered like I can see what I would do
differently I of course remember those
really clearly because I hung on to them
so tightly right right they were
definitely way outweigh in this case
yeah
and you're raising something
that's super common whether you're a
writer or just a human which is you're
criticizing something you hate this
thing but actually that's don't you
understand that's the best part of me
like that's what everybody else loves
and so you get
conflicting conflicting reader feedback
right you say more about that the part
that other people like about you is that
sort of contribution and reclaiming of
agency is that what you mean or no that
off often the things that we get
feedback about from some people our
reaction is like okay well that's just
contradictory because everybody else is
telling me that that's one of the things
that they love about
me I see right so talk to me by the way
about reader feedback that you get
because I do think it goes into
different buckets some is just well
people have different preferences right
and so some people love this part some
people hate this part or wish it were
different well I should say a few things
the first is that I I try to in the case
of reader feedback which is different
from proof reader feedback they're very
different yes because when I reach out
to proof readers I know the sample size
if I reach out to 10 proof readers I can
look at which responses are positive
negative neutral 10 out of 10 but when
you get negative feedback or criticism
there's a selection bias
right if you if you are operating a
customer service hotline chances are
that people who are thrilled with their
experience are not going to be the ones
who call in right or they're going to be
far fewer so it's easy to sometimes
perceive that something
is being uniformly across the board
criticized when in
reality for instance this has happened
in the podcast where I've talked about
certain things that I've done or said
that have come under Fire and then
people come out of the woodwork to say
hey we are actually the silent majority
who think it's great or totally fine but
we're not the ones who are on Twitter
yelling and screaming about it right
yeah so I just want to point out that
sort of selection bias that I try to be
aware of
with I pay more attention
to proofreader feedback generally than I
do reader feedback I pay attention to
both for instance I was just giving
someone this example last last night
4our work week came out in 2007 and
there was a quote at the head of a
chapter from Bill Cosby about breaking
the rules that are set for you in an
industry and thank God that a number of
readers pointed out maybe that should be
taken out for the next Printing and of
course I agreed with that and took it
out yeah we hear it quite differently
yeah there's no upside to that only
downside it doesn't it detracts from the
point I'm trying to
make and it's it's a distraction not an
addition right there there's really no
upside for the reader or for me in
having that in with proof readers and
this will tie into the reader
feedback I I'm sending say a given
chapter or chapters to professional
writers who are friends of mine who
ideally have different sensibilities
also to
nonprofessional writers so let's just
call them lay audience readers and I'm
generally
asking first and foremost what do you
find confusing highlight anything that
is unclear or confusing
second
highlight if I could only keep 20% of
this chapter what I should absolutely
keep great question and then if I had to
cut 20% have to which 20% would you cut
and my rule with the proof readers is if
one person among my small selection I've
selected for good
reasons if they love it it stays in yep
and to take something out usually
requires a pattern so if more than one
person says take this out it's slow it's
confusing it doesn't pull its own weight
whatever that happens to be then I take
it out those are my three biggest I mean
if I added one moreon I would say please
note in the margins or in the document
anywhere your mind starts to wander M
mhm M right so anytime you start
thinking about your to-do list or your
email or something else that's an
indication that I'm not building
sufficient traction and momentum in the
piece to keep you engaged and I have to
fix that yeah those are the things I
focus on the connection is broken
between yeah your the voice of the book
and the reader exactly it's just not
compelling enough so I pay attention to
those things and there are some
revisions that I've made over time where
again there's there's not enough value
and upside to the reader or anyone else
to justify a counterargument on my part
right for instance in the 4-Hour Work
week again I use the word at
one point and it's not going to
personally offend most people reading it
but it is outdated and it just wasn't
necessary it wasn't a critical piece of
a story I could take it out I didn't
feel like I was compromising the
Integrity of the writing by taking it
out so so I took it out but
in in the case of your
example I would love to know how you
personally feel about it about the
revision and the editing of that because
for instance as I think
about my preparation right now that I am
undertaking for a trip starting next
week where I'm going to be off the grid
in some
very uh remote in some cases possibly
dangerous environments I'm going with
someone who's former military it's a
long story that I won't get into but
part of our conversation largely
directed by him has been what we should
wear how we should pack specifically to
minimize the likelihood of being a
Target and different types of
behavior different types
of decision making that are intended
to minimize the likely hood or reduce
the likelihood of bad things happening
right yeah and it would
be from my perspective it would be
irresponsible not to have that
conversation and I'm grateful to have
someone on my team who has a lot of
experience in these
environments so this is just a way to
say I could say well these bad things
shouldn't happen
or you know these aggressors shouldn't
have aggressive behavior but these
things do happen they will continue to
happen and so for me it's a question of
risk
mitigation and of assuming some degree
of agency so that we don't feel like a
piece of Driftwood being thrown around
in an unpredictable sea entirely right
but how did you end up feeling about
making the revision and by the way I'm
not saying you should or shouldn't have
made the revision I'm just curious how
it sits with you after the fact
mixed of course yeah on the one hand
relieved like we we wrote every
different possible version to try to fix
it as possible and it's just like you
know what it's just not going it's not
serving our purposes yeah and it might
be too close to home too
personal so that my sense of it is
muddied and we really need to hear the
impact that it's having which is not
helping our cause
and it is such an important issue for so
many
people these days male and female that
it feels to me like a conversation
about all of the ways in which that
feels painful and we can feel powerless
and stuck
Etc feels like an important sort of
topic
and it's a it's a conversation that I
have with with
people a few times a year who come to me
to say I need help with this
situation so I'm mourning a little bit
that loss and I'm at the same time
persuaded the use of that particular
example in this context was not helping
so let's just let it go and and let me
think about what I need to learn about
my
own need to somehow have my the
particularities of my experience feel
heard by readers rather than saying the
purpose is to bring forward your own so
that's the point here and Sheil you're
missing the
point can we circle to the reader
feedback proof reader feedback right oh
sure and also I asked you to bookmark
something that we can come back to or
not you mentioned women overseas maybe
not solely women but who have contended
with much more extreme examples of your
situation so if we want to come back to
that happy to come back to it but yes we
can also talk about proof reader
feedback so however you want to to lead
us let's go to proofreader feedback
because one of the things I really love
about how clear you are with your proof
readers is that you are
implicitly letting them know what kind
of feedback you're asking for and this
is one of the typical mistakes that we
make which is that we say hey could you
take a look at this and give me some
feedback do you have any feedback for me
is an incredibly hard question to answer
yeah very ambiguous very ambiguous it's
like how honest should I be should I
prepared Etc and if these people are
your friends well I choose my
friends these
days I would say with one critical leg
of the stool being their ability and
eagerness
to give
me what might be considered difficult
feedback right call my baby ugly if need
be to save me some pain later yeah
yeah and but early on and I'm sorry to
Dr but just to offer a contrast early on
I would ask friends of mine to read and
give me feedback in just as many words
and many of them assumed I was looking
for moral support so they would be like
oh I really liked this and this and this
and they'd leave out the fact that they
couldn't make any sense of three other
things and really hated two other things
but yeah I was not surgical in my
request so they gave me what they
inferred I wanted which was a pat on the
back and a pat on the head and that's
not actually what I was asking for but
that was was my fault yes and and I
think that's a big thing that I have
learned from the feedback mhm work yeah
when you say my fault what do you mean
yeah I felt a little resistance there so
I they could have if they wanted to if
they had been more proactive they could
have asked me to refine or they could
have taken a role
in teasing out more precise a more
precise request so I don't want to put
it all on me but I also fumbled the ball
right so they could have picked it up
but I also fumbled it a bit I think
you're exactly right which
is to have
a rich and meaningful feedback
conversation there's responsibility on
both
sides and you're pretty clear and your
friends have
learned the ones who didn't learn didn't
make the cut anymore so they have
learned what you value in terms of
pretty candid coaching and evaluation
and actually may I add one more thing
yeah the people who are best at giving
feedback will actually ask
for they will sometimes ask for further
refinements of my request they'll be
like okay well when you say this is what
you're really looking for this or this
they will drill down until they're like
yes I can repeat back exactly what
you're asking of me great deadline next
Monday perfect and then they're on it
something like that yeah and I think it
takes that Exchange so you I'm sure you
have this experience which I also have
which is that other people hand me their
manuscripts this was true two weeks ago
and say could you take a look at this
and give me some feedback and I have
learned that I need to say more like can
you say more about what would be helpful
to you at this stage and just to put a
finer point on it one of the things that
has really helped me is to understand
that there are really three kinds of
feedback mhm we need all three over time
to learn and grow but we might need
different types of different times and
the the first is
appreciation and sometimes with a
manuscript at the stage it's at what you
need to know is like is there anything
here of value like what do you what do
you like here because I just need a
little encouragement to keep going right
and I think the appreciation plays a
huge role in our willingness to stay
engaged over time in the relationship if
I feel like really see me and get how
hard I'm working or there are things
that you like and appreciate about me
even in the midst of us having some
struggle the second kind is coaching
coaching is anything designed to help it
be better help me be better you're being
really clear with your
readers like tell me what's confusing
coach me on where I'm not being clear MH
and coaching of course is the big engine
for Learning and change and Improvement
but you're also actually asking for the
Third Kind of feedback which is
evaluation like rate or rank it and what
you're saying is there's a standard for
what stays and what
goes tell me what must stay like it well
meets the standard for being essential
tell me what doesn't make the cut in
your
view and that's actually
helpful to me so you're actually asking
primarily for coaching and evaluation
in your request and when people are that
clear about what they're looking for
it's so much
easier to
respond if I could just bounce off of
that a few things the first is that I
will also frequently not ask someone to
check all of those boxes right often
it's like one thing right when I'm
asking professional writers especially
they have their own deadlines they have
their own work reading my stuff is not
their job so I'm asking asking them for
a favor very often I will
ask them to just indicate the 20% that
has to go or the 20% that has to stay or
just indicate what is unclear or slow
where you start to think about other
things MH and I'll make up
for the lightness of that request by
adding more people I'll just have more
proof readers instead of more requests
per proof reader and I I should also say
I want to give credit where credit is
due so stevenh prfi incredible writer in
his own right and has written the war of
Art and many other books talks about
resistance and he became an
informal coach therapist when I was
working on fiction for the first time
about let's call it a year ago and I
sent him some very early drafts and
asked asked him for
feedback being I think in some respects
masochistic I asked him to just vivisect
my work and his response was basically
I've read it I want to read more just
keep going and what I gleaned from that
was that he said that's great kid I
recognize that you want me to tear this
apart and that's not what you need right
now so I'm actually going to give you
the appreciation not the coaching and
evaluation I'm going to give you like
the the pat on the back and the kick in
the ass just to keep going because
actually that's what you need right now
and he was right of course I'm
speculating a lot about his inner
experience but that's I think the
intention behind the feedback that he
gave me so how do people take this
framework the three kind of
feedback
and put it into practice I suppose
what are some ways that people might
think
about carrying that into their day they
listen to this they carry it into their
day or their week one thing that helps
is just to
be
clearer about what you're short on right
now or what you're asking someone forh
or if you're being asked to give
feedback to ask them and maybe not trust
their answer right what I hear him
saying is
implicitly we're
speculating maybe I think what you just
need is is the encouragement to keep
going right now he could also be
thinking in the early stages of any
fiction there are a hundred things wrong
with it but you're not you don't figure
out what they are until you're further
down the road and you are coming back
and revising so you're just not at the
stage that's a good match for specific
coaching right because you just need to
keep going once you see where this Arc
goes you'll back up and see and figure
out what needs to change who knows he's
got some philosophy in his own
head in terms of getting specific about
things you can do with this framework of
types of feedback they have different
purposes easy way to remember them is
Ace AC appreciation coaching and
evaluation we need all three could you
just perhaps spend a little more time
differentiating between coaching and
evaluation
I could see mixing those up totally I
could see personally mixing those up I
think of coaching as part valuation so
how should we distinguish those two they
often get tangled and often I'm very
clear that what I'm offering you is
coaching for reasons that have to do
with your personality problems you're
hearing it as judgment or evaluation
right so there's often a mismatch
between what the giver thinks they're
doing and what the receiver hears
yeah it happens a lot and partly that
reflects the fact that packed into
implicit in any coaching is a little bit
of evaluation because if I'm giving you
a suggestion on how to do it better it
suggests that you could be doing it
better and so we hear that which hits an
identity thing right okay so is coaching
the what and the how of improving
whereas the evaluation is basically fail
pass A+ it's it's basically giving
someone a value judgment on their work
good enough not good enough and then the
coaching is here are the steps to take
yeah so we have some set of
standards
for whether this manuscript is ready to
go is it ready to go out or not
standards for performance expectations
in this role here's what we would expect
from
you grades obviously here's what I'm
looking for in terms of the quality of
your work so yes evaluation
is rating or ranking against some set of
expectations or standards how you
measure up so you know just asking am I
on track for what you expected from me
in this new
role so the question of how is this
going in our
relationship is often how are you
feeling about whether this is still
exceeding your expectations or starting
to feel
wanting that goes along with a whole
bunch of coaching right potentially for
what I wish you would do the two are
very closely related but we have the
biggest emotional reaction to the
evaluation part
because because we hate being
judged it's hard it's really hard to
feel
judged and so we're quick to hear it in
anything I was looking looking at some
of the prep notes and
one tactic or maybe it's more of a
practice that I'd love for you to
describe is the phone a friend because
this seems like a
lowrisk high reward way
to
develop to cultivate the ability to look
at things from multiple perspectives and
to receive
feedback well so the supportive mirror
the honest mirror could you describe for
folks what the phone a friend means here
part of the challenge of receiving
feedback is as I think I mentioned a
little while ago when feedback is
incoming you know formal or informal I'm
scanning for what's wrong with it as
human beings we're we very good at wrong
spotting you know
what they're saying isn't true that's
not exactly how it happened or that in
the context that wasn't what was going
to help who is giving it to me there's
all kinds of problems I don't like them
I don't trust them I don't want to be
like them they don't know what they're
talking
about you know why I suspect they're
giving it to
me they've got their own agenda for how
they want me to
change when and where and how they gave
it to me was outrageous and ridiculous
so if I can come up with what's wrong
with it it then I can safely set it
aside and relax and go on with my
life and the problem with that is that
you're always going to be able to find
something wrong with the feedback that
you get and it could be 90% wrong right
but that last
10% might be just what I need to be
thinking about in order to change and
grow so for instance what they
understood happened and why I did
it doesn't make sense and and their
suggestion for what to do instead
wouldn't work
however maybe the 10% is that they're
highlighting that this is maybe a bigger
problem than I thought it was I have my
own diagnosis and I'll come up with my
own solution but they're putting
something on my plate that maybe wasn't
as visible to me
before part of the skill of becoming a
better receiver is not letting my
triggered reaction and my wrong spotting
be the end of the story to throw it all
out but
instead to First work to understand the
feedback then I can decide and sort what
is right about it what's wrong with it
now that's really hard for me to do by
myself for a bunch of reasons in terms
of sort of the challenge to see what the
giver means and the challenge to see
myself accurately and all of that and so
I can phone a friend to
help and by the way I'm going to phone a
friend anyway when I get upsetting
feedback I'm gonna go complain to
somebody else about it
right over a glass of wine and and we're
going to make a big list about what's
wrong with this other person and all the
ways in which they're wrong
and so what I can do is I can reach out
to somebody I trust which I'm going to
do anyway and ask I'm implicitly asking
them to be what we call a supportive
mirror to join me in seeing what's wrong
with it because if I'm really devastated
by it I'm not in a place where I can
learn anyway like this one thing and
this one mistake is the whole story
about me and I'm so knocked off
balance or if you're just annoyed enough
that you're spun up spun up and
rejecting it and pissed off right
absolutely this is just more evidence of
what's wrong with
them yeah so I'm not in a great place
and I need somebody else to join me in
just getting myself back to a place
where I can maybe hear what might be
right about it so asking a friend to
really two questions ask you two
questions and help you process in two
directions one is what we're doing
naturally which is be a supportive
mirror join me in asking what's wrong
with this feedback usually we quit there
and go
home because now we feel better and in
the meantime our friend is
thinking uh it's not totally off base
and so we need to give them permission
to then when we're ready to shift and be
what we call an honest
mirror and to help us see what might be
right about it what might
be legitimate and maybe hard for for me
to
see when we have a visual for the
supportive mirror it's like a gold
gilded frame show me my best in
flattering light they're wrong I'm
okay I'm fabulous and we do need that
it's important not to skip it and the
what might be right about it is more
like Black Mirror it's like a Black
Mirror the the mirror that we often use
is actually you know that hand mirror
that you find in in barber shops or hair
salons sure that's the one and the
reason also Black Mirror the reason that
that we use that shape of mirror is
because when the barber the hairstylist
shows it to you they're showing you the
back of your head oh right when they
walk behind you yeah they spin you
around so you can appreciate what an
amazing job they did but they're
actually handing it to you to help you
see something that you can't see by
yourself so being an honest smir is
asking a friend to help you see what
might be right about this feedback what
do you think I should probably hear
embedded in
it okay so I I definitely encourage
people to do this I mean
I naturally do this with a number of my
close friends MH is ask them for that
barber spin around look at the back of
the head right right so well here's a
question that
is it's not directly related but it's
certainly thematically mhm aligned with
what we're talking about in this
conversation also what we talked about
in our last conversation things have
changed since we last spoke I
am back in the singles Arena and one
thing that has struck me is almost no
number
of dinners every one or two
weeks where everyone's on best behavior
allows you to see what people are like
in difficult conversations or unless
it's heavily engineered it's it's
unlikely to come up organically right
you know unless who knows the waiter
spills tomato juice on her dress and she
freaks out and smashes a glass on the
floor and starts yelling at people okay
fine but you're like well thanks for the
clarity yeah I haven't yet architected
something like that but I I am curious
to
know and I'll give a counter example
actually I'm not going to name names but
I was I was out to dinner with someone I
know
who last I saw
him was actually he was single then
decided he wanted to find a partner and
basically made a commitment he had a one
pager he would show each person on a
date and he'd be like what do you think
of this one pager this is what I'm
looking for oh my gosh what is on the
one pager we have to know well I don't
want to dox him but a lot of women opted
nothing crazy but he wants a lot of kids
as an example and a lot of women opted
out and he's like great I don't want to
waste your time and that was that some
were like actually this is very
interesting and if he decided that he
wanted to give someone a serious shot he
would say I can make a commitment to you
which is in six months we'll either be
engaged or we'll be separated I won't
drag this out for a really long time but
his approach is then to spend a lot of
time with that person basically try to
try to effectively move in with them for
you know two or three weeks and see what
happens I don't know if I'm ready to
make the jump to that end of the
spectrum but it does make some sense in
so much as kind of fiddling around
seeing each other intermittently not
really getting a good read of how
someone handles conflict or difficult
conversations or life when they are
compromised like run down low on sleep
mhm seems like it could waste a lot of
time and you could just go on these
multi-month boondoggles without either
side getting a super clear read of the
other do you have any thoughts on how to
sort of figure this out sooner I mean I
certainly have had the experience of say
going on a week-long trip with someone
and you see how they handle their
luggage getting lost or whatever might
be
but are there any other simple or
elegant or obvious approaches that I am
just missing where maybe you could sus
out a bunch in a
conversation over dinner and I'm just
not finding the path of least resistance
with with questions that that really
deliver do you have any thoughts about
any of this well first I'll note the
efficiency orientation toward dating
yeah well I'm not getting any younger
right I mean I know I know seriously I
mean I'm not actually saying it's wrong
at all but it's the
lens sure right yes you name the lens
the 4-Hour relationship assessment yes
courtship that's exactly that's your
next
book maybe it's fiction maybe it's
fiction got a ways to go before I'll
feel remotely qualified to write
anything yeah yeah and I think you're
exactly right which is early in the
relationship we're all on our best
behavior and sometimes not because it's
hard but because we're just excited and
appreciated and flooded with all of the
positive feelings
and so how we handle stress and how we
handle conflict doesn't come up for a
while at least experientially doesn't
come up unless as you say you happen to
see it because something happens while
you're together with someone else who
they don't have this protective positive
set of feelings about whether that's
because you're traveling together or
or something happens at the
restaurant and I would say that that's a
big red flag
obviously if they freak out and start
screaming at the weight staff freak out
yes
yes it's funny because sometimes it
should freak us out
when they're they don't address it at
all too because that's not actually
going to be good in the long term in the
relationship because it's like
well that's great but now you're not
going to say something with me mhm some
of it is is that it's a
topic I mean even when we are
interviewing teaching fellows because we
work together in a pretty intense
January term where we're together you
know from 9 to 5 6 seven8 preparing for
the next day because it's an intense
three-week
term class all day every day one of the
questions we ask is like talk to me
about how you experience and handle
stress what stresses you out and
what helps you and what doesn't help
you
similarly you know talk to me about how
conflict was handled in your
family or in your past
relationships in ways that felt right to
you or that felt have felt frustrating
or dysfunctional to you I mean it's a
really interesting and rewarding topic
of conversation whether their espoused
theory for what they think they do
matches is what they actually do
sometimes they don't exactly what we
think we're doing is not what other
people actually see however it at least
puts on the table what they think they
do how would you answer those questions
in terms of how you handle conflict and
stress and what helps how I personally
handle conflict and stress yeah you know
I owe my ex a huge dead of gratitude in
the sense that I think on many levels
she was and is very emotionally
intelligent very very very socially
intelligent so I learned a lot through
osmosis and through coaching I was not
always
the most enthusiastic recipient of said
coaching but nonetheless right right
like I'm sorry I was not realizing that
I had hired you for this evening yes so
I would
say I tend to like to address conflict
openly so we may come back to what you
mentioned earlier where some people have
giving you the feedback that you're too
quick to speak uph I do this has been
consistent for a very long time we spoke
about this in the last conversation but
timing of those conversations matters a
lot for me late at night when I've had a
full after a full day when I'm getting
ready to wind down and I already have
issues with an overactive mind and onset
insomnia is not going to generally have
the best outcome yeah so experimenting
with other times shorter duration right
start and end time type of quick checkin
clearing conversations is very effective
for me I found the book getting the love
you want and some of the Frameworks
asking for redus having a shared
language that allows you
to I suppose resolve things with
shorthand but agreeing upfront that you
going to have that shared language and
those practices at least for a period of
time as an experiment I think is super
helpful so I feel like I handle conflict
reasonably well uh in my household
though to answer that part I would
say I
had and this may not be totally fair but
I think it's a decent read I had one um
maybe the term you would use as a like a
blame absorber mhm in the form of my mom
where I very conflict diverse quick to
apologize for
everything and then my dad and if if
he's listening sorry Dad but blame
deflector in the sense that things
tended to be taken very personally
tended to get very heated very
defensive why is everyone always ganging
up on me or fill in the
blank and to that
extent didn't have had an easier time
interacting with my mom than my dad but
both of those coping mechanisms or
strategies I have found myself using and
neither of them works very well yeah the
deflecting for reasons that are perhaps
more obvious the blame
absorbing I would say often times
because
if I want a conversation to end if the
ask isn't clear if for
instance I'm being given coaching but
there are no examples that can be
provided and I just see no resolution in
sight I am inclined to apologize just to
make that conversation go away because I
don't see it going anywhere helpful but
then if I find myself doing that
repeatedly and this is true for a lot of
people not just me having a stewing
resentment that develops because the
apologies aren't
really one could say sincere one could
say not
really deserved possibly in some
instances right it's just an it's it's a
way to take the exit ramp off of this
highway of fruitless conversation or
debate or argument so I I I would say I
did not grow up with great models in the
household however I would credit
my time in sports and having coaches I
really respected with helping me to
accept
coaching quite easily including very
harsh kind of old
country style yeah feedback Jersey
Gregor comes to mind who's this former
world record holder and Olympic
weightlifting who's an incredible coach
incredibly good at rehab and addressing
injuries and his style of feedback to
give you an idea at one point we're
having a conversation early on over
black tea this is the intake
conversation in California long time ago
and he he was looking at me sort of
narrowing his eyes as he drank his black
tea and he reached across and he kind of
pinched my like Peck like grabbed my
almost grabb my nipple like gave it a
pinch and he leaned back and he said you
are too
fat
but the guy has the bonafides right he's
a real performer he has an excellent
track record and I was like okay let's
call spade a spade yeah I could probably
do without like the late night pizza
binges after having uh maybe one or two
glasses of wine that I shouldn't have
had right like yeah like okay like I
could put up a fuss but this guy is very
straight yeah he's not exaggerating his
tone is very matter of fact he's not
saying it in some kind of finger
wagging holier than now way it's just a
statement of objective fact so fine and
so I would say that I I feel very
fortunate that in a sports capacity and
also why I think mandatory sports are an
excellent excellent idea for youth in
general I became very comfortable with
Fast Direct feedback in those settings
so the way that I navigate conflict and
feedback is very context dependent
and I would say that over the last 5
years the way that I am able to
metabolize comfortably feedback and
elicit feedback in
my Intimate Relationships or personal
relationships let's say has has become
much closer to what I'm able to do in
the sports or skill acquisition Arena
because I can do that with language and
other things as well it's not just
physical
Sports so that's the
long story long I guess I'm happy to to
keep going though if you want to keep me
in the hot seat I kept you in the hot
seat for a while so certainly there's
there's more more digging we can do I'm
happy to do it a couple things that
strike me one is your experience with
him with jersey with the coach yep and
also the guy that you're going to be
traveling with who's coaching you on
what to pack and what to wear and how to
stay under the
radar you are hiring them with that
specific job in mind you're hiring them
because you believe that they have
expertise and you are eager to hear
their coaching it's not always easy to
hear but the role is clear the friend is
just a friend who happens to come with
the benefit of being someone a I really
really respect as an operator in the
world yeah which is important absolutely
very relevant to how I receive feedback
yeah who's better better than me in so
many departments more skilled than I am
more practiced than I am in so many
capacities that it's very easy for me to
receive his feedback which is also very
brief very understated very direct says
it with a smile it's just it's not just
the content but the tone also as a very
matter of fact yeah so yes but it's it's
part of my expectation in those
relationships that that type of feedback
is something I value very
highly yeah and so that's one of the
conundrums of feedback is why is it that
sometimes we're so eager for it and even
when it's rude and
surprising with the pinch um we're
grateful for it a little faster we're
like okay fair fair you know I'll I'll
take that on board
when other times somebody if on a second
date and I really into some
she was like wow you are too fat I don't
think i' take it as well yeah not to
future dates just cross that off your
list
well very unlikely to happen but like
the exact same feedback different person
different place yes yeah I would I would
feel very differently about it
absolutely so this is one of the
conundrums by the way of feedback which
is why is it that sometimes I actually
it does feel like a gift and I'm
grateful for it and other times like
yeah screw you we're done
so so you're dead to me you're dead to
me we don't even need to finish
dinner and speaking of sexual harassment
stop pinching my back
so we're gon to come full circle
here so I'll maybe make a general
observation and then I want to go back
to your parents a little bit too but the
general observation is that one of the
things that we start to notice is that
when we have a reaction to
feedback there are sort of three kinds
of triggered reactions we have so one is
what we call a truth trigger what you're
saying isn't right wouldn't work good
bad advice it's all about evaluating the
quality of what the person is telling
you would help you the second is what we
call a relationship trigger which has
everything to do with who's giving you
the
feedback whether you trust them whether
you like them whether you think they
know what they're talking about whether
they really have your best interest of
mind or their own agenda
we often have a bigger reaction to the
who than the what and then the third is
what we call an identity trigger which
is partly the story we tell about who we
are and whether that feels threatened or
not but
also in the course of the feedback work
we uncovered some evidence that suggests
that in terms of sensitivity to
feedback how upset we get and how long
it takes us to recover that can vary by
up to 3,000 % can you say that one more
time our
sensitivity to
feedback and other things happening in
our lives by the way it's not just
feedback but in terms of how upset we
get how activated we get and how long it
takes us to recover so you lying
awake in the wake of the
argument arguments are partly who's the
problem which one of us is the problem
and which one of us needs to change in
many
cases
that how long it takes us to recover can
vary by up to 3,000% and some of that is
just the way we're wired some of that is
past
experience or something around trauma
that gets tripped that
changes your
sensitivity so part of the challenge is
understanding
like I am having a triggered reaction to
what's happening whether that's feedback
or conflict and in what
ways is that making it harder for me to
hear what might be right about what
you're
saying and and see what's important so
to Circle all the way back around to the
dating
question part of what you're trying to
figure out when you're dating is well
who are you you know what's different or
cool and or
complimentary about this new person that
I'm getting to know a little bit and
it's really hard in the wake of a
breakup because the Baseline that you're
comparing to is someone that you know
incredibly well and have a ton of
history and it's really hard to close
that Gap when that person is the
Baseline I'm curious about your
reactions to that another question is
how who am I in this relationship as
it's starting to develop do I like the
way that I am in this relationship
that's a big one for me yeah right does
this person help me to be a better
version of myself
or is this person sort of summoning the
Demons of my lesser self yeah exactly
that's a real thing it's a real thing
I'll name the third thing and then we'll
come back to this thing which is just
okay what's the you plus me
combination how authentic and honest are
we being with each other do I know what
to expect do I know how you feel do you
know how I feel Etc and how do we handle
the inevitable friction that we're going
to have because in any two combination
of two people you've got lots of things
that are complimentary and some things
that are going to have some friction
just because you have really different
preferences and habits and interests and
whatever and in how we handle that does
it bring out the better part of me or
the worst part of me and vice versa and
does it feel Fair also or does it feel
like one of us is always the one who to
apologize or to
change say a little bit more about
bringing out the better parts of you and
the worst parts of you well let me
preface that by saying I did a Q&A with
some of my audience
yesterday
and if my talking
about if my talking about relationship
stuff on the podcast could be a roar
shock test holy do I get a lot of
stuff projected on me there were so many
questions like Tim why can't you hold on
to a partner da da da da da like what
haven't why can't you learn the lesson
about this this and this all of these
things and I would just say just briefly
that I actually if you were to talk to
my last few exes who I'm still on good
terms with they would I think all say
that I'm a really good boyfriend I'm not
perfect but I talk about this in the
same way that I might if I had a an
expert on language learning on
I would ask them how I could improve in
language learning even though I think
I'm pretty good at it and have a
demonstrated track record I would still
want to be better because I know there's
room for improvement so I just want to
set the table a little bit so that I
maybe stem the flow of you know Tim why
can't you figure anything out in
relationship type questions in my open
Q&A sessions that that I do every once
in a while but but you're naming that
that's really like can't I figure out
because it's easier for me to
see you not figuring something out but
partly my seeing that is motivated by in
my own life why can't I figure out
what's going on wrong in my own
relationship or where I'm stuck or it
might be I was stuck for a long time and
gosh I want to help you but it's hard
for us to see a lot of it is people
vomiting their own stuff totally the
roar Shack yeah so I just
wanted yeah
so yes yes and yes and to I would say
that more than almost any of the
questions or criteria you mentioned the
one that gives me a clear signal is do I
like who I am around this person that's
it
and some matches work better than others
obviously some combinations are better
than others and sometimes there are
massive trade-offs maybe you have
excellent chemistry with someone but
it's also so combustible mhm and
the
communication is probably sort of
handicapped in some way that's going to
be disastrous ultimately right
so the read that I ask though because
it's something that I can confirm myself
if I ask a question about someone else
or I make an assumption for instance
that based on how they're interacting in
a first or second date I think they're
going to be really bad at deescalate in
Conflict they seem to interrupt and step
on top of me a lot I might say it seems
like X and they say oh wow well you said
I hated or loved X and I've said well
actually no that's a very exaggerated
version of what I just said but those
are not my words and getting this taste
test I might infer that they would be
bad at De escalating conflict but I
can't really know that for sure based on
a first date maybe they're just
maybe they had too much coffee who
knows I can assess though how I
feel hopefully with higher Fidelity so I
I pay attention to that because I think
it's a more
reliable knowable
defensible feeling or assessment so I I
do I do pay a lot of attention to that
right is someone dredging up all the
stuff that I haven't had to deal with
for for a while MH and now it's it's not
to say I can easily point to causality
maybe there are other things that are
happening that day or that week or that
month that have set the conditions or do
I feel at ease are we laughing easily
together Etc am I feeling good about Who
I Am with this person is very much at
the top of my
list yeah
and part of what I love about that is
that you're paying attention
to what is being called
forward years ago I was in one of those
on again off again break up get back
together terrible
relationships that I couldn't quite see
my way out of at the
time and my mom who doesn't tend to say
much explicitly MH my mom gave lots of
generalized coaching and instruction to
us as kids but she wouldn't tend to
comment on something specific happening
in the moment right she'd give general
advice it was up to you to figure out oh
this is things yeah one of those things
so she wouldn't she'd kind of leave you
alone in the middle of it but in the
middle of it she said to me one night
you know what this stage I don't know
that it's supposed to be this
hard yeah and and somehow that was like
the light bulb that was
like yeah actually it's not supposed to
be this hard this early MH
so I I was so appreciative at the time
and it was just an
observation so I'll also then observe
that the focusing on gosh where is this
I'm really enjoying the conversation
this is really bringing forward my best
self then sits in tension with and and
what happens when we get in
conflict because then it doesn't test
that
sometimes so what's your experience with
that I would say that there's someone
trying to make you feel good right it's
it's not that hard right if you're if we
just go with like the heteronormative
thing for a second right if if a woman
laughs at your jokes you feel great so
so it's not hard for a woman to realize
that and play that hand very well
there's there's someone trying to make
you feel good and then there's just how
you feel from a state perspective being
around them being exposed to them and so
I would
say it doesn't show you the play byplay
of how something will unfold in conflict
and if someone is over the toop cheerful
all the time that is definitely a yellow
flag for me because that isn't
reality
and when the pendulum swings really far
and that towards the mask of everything
is always great it in my experience
tends to swing very hard back in the
other direction equally into the the
darkness so I'm cautious around that but
I would say
that if someone can make me
feel
physiologically calm and relaxed and
that is a byproduct of their personality
not necessarily the words they say or
how they laugh at my
jokes that that
often I think is a a foreshadowing of
having a more easeful time in Conflict
yeah if I am less activated by the
combination of our two personalities in
general when things are heightened I
will probably be more heightened but
maybe not DEFCON 5 in which case I will
just be able to speak listen pause
suggest we table things for a while and
come back to them when we're a little de
escalated more
effectively at least that's how I
suppose I'm thinking about it now that I
have to put words to
it well and and you're reminding me of
of something that we were talking about
last
time and that you've
mentioned today as well which is working
something through two
resolution and I'm curious
about what resolution feels like or
looks like in other words I think in
lots of interactions and
relationship someone is
saying hey you did that thing
again
and by the way I just want to note I'm
annoyed right now because fill in the
blank and noting it helps
me actually say like and we don't have
to talk about it now but I just needed
to name it so that I don't instead act
passive aggressively annoyed about it
and pretend I'm
not and then can we live in that space
can we hold that space and we don't have
to totally unpack it right this very
minute and and sometimes that's enough
you know it's a chronic thing between us
you know and I'm just noting it and can
we live in that space both of
us do we feel equally comfortable or
does one of us say well now that you've
said you're annoyed like we we've got to
stop everything and spend a couple hours
unpacking it it's my
nightmare yeah yeah I mean I kind of
feel a lot of processing just like a lot
of presentations fail from too much
information not too little
information in the sense
that what does resolution look like to
me if that's the question I would answer
that
I think the simplest way to achieve
resolution is to have some agreement of
what that looks like in a shared
framework like something out of one of
your books or something from getting the
love you want where there is there are
actual triage
tools that have determined end points
right whether the endpoint is I just
want to say this right now we don't need
to address it I'm not asking for
processing
but could we schedule a time talk about
it great like episode complete right I'm
not saying that is the one and only tool
the tool could
be some version of non-violent
communication where you know when X Y
and Z happened I felt this the story I
make around that is this could I ask you
blank right having a clear request and
agreement and then episode complete
right so I think it's just having a a
mutual
agreement as to what those exchanges
look like I mean a question that I want
to ask because this came up in a number
of places in our last conversation but
we didn't dig into this one piece in
particular it's related
to a line that I'll read and there are a
few different versions of this but given
gutman's research about 2third of our
conflicts and long-term relationships
are not really resolvable the task isn't
to resolve them once and for all it's to
figure out a way to handle them or
navigate them and manage them together
that feels okay and good right so to
zoom out I do want to ask you about that
and
specifically is the only way to figure
that out to basically be with someone
for six
months or a year but broadly speaking
I'm wondering what you think of the Gman
Institute they get cited all the time
because
sure people have heard and I'm going to
get the specifics wrong here but that
the founders of the Goin Institute could
look at five minutes of video footage of
a couple and with 95 plus perc accuracy
predict who would be divorced within the
next three years or whatever it might be
right people have heard these anecdotes
what is the Goin Institute and what do
you think the strengths and weaknesses
are to the extent that you've been able
to glean either of those things I think
that the work that they're doing is
fascinating and additive and there just
aren't particularly when they started
there
weren't people really
studying marriage and long-term
relationships good bad and everything in
between right so there might be talk
about why did things break down but you
weren't also looking at what was working
for other couples MH and from my point
of view of course they're focused on
what's most important which is that they
are inviting couples in they're inviting
them to talk about a topic that is
stressful so they're inviting them to
have a difficult
conversation and they're hooking them up
to heart monitors and all of that and
then they're recording all that data and
then they're following the couple and
noticing what what correlates with
either self-reporting being happily
married and doing that over
time because sometimes people will
self-report being happily married and
then they divorce and then they're going
back and saying well actually I wasn't
happily married which may be revisionist
Memory but also may
be it was good enough for me to be happy
but then we weren't talking about what
we needed to talk about because a lot of
the there's a portion of those the good
was good enough but the bad wasn't being
addressed right exactly the bad wasn't
being addressed so it felt like well we
never argued about anything well it's
because one of us wasn't speaking up to
say the things that were bothering us
because it was good
enough so I think that the work that
they're doing is incredibly valuable and
it's very
descriptive meaning it's identifying
what are the variables so you know ey
rolling is one of one of the things that
is most closely correlated with the
relationship fraying right and divorce
partly because eye rolling is just an
external indicator of internal here we
go again I'm not really listening
anymore what they code AS contempt yeah
I'm not aware of a single culture where
eye rolling has a positive indication
right exactly so what they're doing is
that they're identifying and describing
what correlates with a
relationship ending or seeming to have
staying power
what what I love about that is that it
lines up so nicely with the prescriptive
work that we do the diagnostic and
prescriptive work that we do to take a
look at well what's really going on
that's getting us stuck why am I rolling
my eyes because I
feel frustrated unheard like we're back
at we're falling back into our usual
pattern where I don't expect there to be
a resolution and I'm exhausted by that
and I don't know how to get out of it so
it it lines up nicely with our
observations about what gets people
stuck and and also then what helps but
it gives us Insight through another lens
about the longer term impact of
that the fact that about a third of the
conflicts tend to be temporal you can
say that they're resolvable or they just
we move on because we had to decide
where to live and we we had we decided
and now we're transient yeah they have
an expiration date yeah we're not
arguing about that
anymore we needed to figure out how to
parent young children we no longer have
young children now we'll just have
conflict about how to parent older
children
so two-thirds are just reflective of the
particularities of you plus me and where
we're going to have some rub and the
question of are we able to notice that
note it and hold it with some humor and
affection for each other in the midst of
it even as we're honest and direct about
you're doing that thing
again and do we feel like I feel seen
and heard and it's a relatively balanced
sense of you know sometimes you get your
way sometimes I get my
way and we're slowly it's getting to be
a less loaded topic rather than a more
loaded topic mhm what's your experience
with the loaded
topics and eye rolling maybe I have very
low tolerance for eye rolling I just
don't have time for people who who
behave that way so that's that's a one
strike your out kind of situation there
are too many amazing people in the world
I and there are too many people who
don't do that also there are plenty of
people who don't engage with that let me
preface I'm going to ask clarifying
question about your question but I will
say that so I was thinking about it a
bit as you were discussing the Gman
Institute that I don't say this much but
I've probably said it a half a dozen
times observing couples at dinners or at
weddings where I'm like they will be
divorced within 3 years 100%
accurate yes yes yeah yeah although I
don't you should just be deputized to
like let people
know right honorary degree from the Gman
Institute that's right I mean I honestly
don't think it takes PUO or Sherlock
Holmes to figure it out I mean to me a
lot of it seems pretty obvious
but the eye rolling making jokes that
are at the expense of the other person
Where You observe one person laughing
who made the joke the other person
clearly not laughing any type of am
mascula which can go both ways but any
any type of cutting
down in a group
environment seems so obviously a recipe
for disaster but when you say the loaded
topics or how I relate to that could you
phrase that a different way what do you
mean by that the topics that are chronic
irritations between us or differences
and then we make meaning out of that the
fact that you know this drives me crazy
and yet you still continue to do
it or this is something we disagree
about and it's still not feeling settled
or good yeah I Suppose there are
different of course different species of
chronic unresolved or maybe
unresolvable friction MH I would say
that certainly in my last handful of
relationships uh it's not like I've had
a ton I mean I've had a few long
relationships we come to a truce I would
say on a lot of those things if we can
kind of laugh at them together and
sometimes they drive one person or the
other crazy but there are these sort of
manageable
differences that can
be more often than not laughed about I
would say for me as someone who has
always battled chronic fatigue and I I
do think that that could be explained
partly by
multiple documented infections with Lyme
disease but there are I'm sure other
contributing
factors the problem problem for me is
not generally the problem unless
somebody really betrays trust or
something like that and does
something that from the outside would be
considered terrible clearly terrible
which I would put up with more of that
when I was very young like a lot of
people like the the exciting person was
worth all sorts of drama I'm just not
right no longer at that place in my life
so I I don't deal with those types of
situations
really but I would say the the problem
for me is is frequently not the problem
itself the situation that is sort of
under discussion it's the method of
discussion and the duration of
discussion so for me if constant
processing becomes a defining feature of
the
relationship that is a meta issue for me
that is very difficult to metabolize
which doesn't mean I don't talk about
problems it's just like we should have a
toolkit that allows us to and also a
degree
of independent resilience and
interpersonal resilience whereby it's
like if someone dropped a piece of gum
on the floor and they don't do it all
the time just pick it up and throw it
out like it's not a big deal right
accommodate the other person does not
require a conversation yeah so I I would
say that for
me most of the
issues at least those that are coming to
mind right now are not big in and of
themselves but if the discussion ends up
feeling like it's just going in circles
upon circles upon circles then I do
struggle with it yeah that I struggle
with and which is certainly not unique
to me every couple I know has some
version of this yeah but certainly My
Hope Is that with someone I'm with long
term the majority of time it is it does
not feel like heavy lifting right like
your mom said to you like at this point
I'm not sure it should be this hard
right something like that yes and the
couples I've talked to who I really
admire who have been together 15 20 plus
years generally all come back with some
version of that it shouldn't be hard all
the time however I find them all very
difficult to model because almost
without exception they met when they
were very young neither person had
anything there were like young and
stupid and loving life
and they met
through
complete luck of the draw circumstance
it would seem oftentimes very early and
sometimes it's like high school or
college
and their lived experience is just very
different from
mine right yeah my life doesn't lend
itself to as much of that now as it
would when I was 16 17 18 20 early 20s
right right yeah so I'm not sure how to
model what they've achieved in other
words yeah part of what you're making me
think about is is a conversation that I
had with my youngest sister
who I got married young I mean I look
back now and I'm like why did I think I
had any business getting married at
MH and so I'm one of those people who
have been married forever and I think my
husband John and I grew up
together in so many ways my youngest
sister got married at
30 7 37 38 and when she
met her husband well at first she
friendzoned him and he wasn't a
contender and then suddenly she had this
epiphany of like oh he's the right
person standing right front he was like
I can wait I have the patience of an
insect as one of
the praying mantis will wait that's
right that's
right we we actually commissioned a
custom song for their wedding and and it
was all about Stacy's big Epiphany you
know and and how patient how patient Dan
had
been I I know you will come around good
for Dan yeah exactly good for both of
them I guess good for both of them and
in real time it didn't take that long it
felt like forever to him but he then
proposed quite quickly mhm my parents
were visiting my sister also lives in
Boston and she left the room and he
suddenly turned to them and
said you know I I just wanted to let you
know how much I am in love with your
daughter and
and I want to ask her to marry me and
spend the rest of my life with her and
my my mother's like well I have some
follow-up
questions my father's like be quiet he
said to me later I wanted to you know
leap across the island and kiss him yes
we love you we think you're
awesome which you know reflects
something about each of my parents but
Stacy in the meantime was out of the
room and so she then walks back in the
room this is a completely out of the
blue topic of conversation they've had
the secret caucus complete yeah and
suddenly it's like like well okay I'm
going to run down and get a allall of
champagne kind of thing so they weren't
officially engaged yet but it was on the
table that they were more or less and
they had been dating for less than a
year how long have they known each other
though about a year oh all right a year
before that or a year it was a year
total no no no yeah oh wow they met
through a mutual friend at a party the
friend had called Dan to say you need to
break up with whoever you're going out
with cuz I'm going to introduce you to
something someone tonight wow but she
didn't I hope they get a bouquet of
flowers every year oh yeah they have
milked that for all it's
worth as they should as they should so
they knew each other for a few months
before she figured it out and then they
were dating in Earnest and then this is
probably nine months after that so after
all the toasts she and I went for a run
together I said how are you feeling and
she's I'm just amazing and I can hardly
believe it
and and also I'm just I'm still waiting
to find out what's wrong with
him and my reaction was well five years
from now you're going to have a a much
more robust answer for that question of
what's wrong with him but the real
question is are they going to be deal
breakers for you and what would the deal
breakers be
and so Tim I'm curious MH given your
experience partly what you're listening
for in the early stages of dating is are
there deal breakers here for
me yeah not because I'm judging this
other person but because I just know
that that combination's not going to
work or whatever and so one of them
sounds like it's endless
processing yeah yeah endless processing
would be one and I want to own my part
obviously
in some of this in the sense that I'm
sure I contributed to situations that
were uncomfortable enough for my
significant other that she felt the need
to process however I do think she also
sort of leans that direction in terms of
sure yeah communication so yes endless
processing or a primary project being
processing like that is expected to
be
a dominant feature of the relationship
necessary for sure but a dominant
feature of the relationship no yeah it
shouldn't feel that hard and if it does
chances are there are things that are
probably irreconcilable differences so
that would be one deal
breaker other deal breakers if somebody
throws sharp elbows that's really what
I'm very wary of for a lot of reasons if
somebody throws sharp elbows if
they are vindictive
if
they speak in a really
aggressive upset way about their
exes those are all red flags for me not
yellow those are red and it's
astonishing what some people and I'm
grateful they do but what some people
will volunteer on first dat in terms of
like oh yeah my ex did this and like I
showed him by like taking a torch and
doing this this and this and I'm like
okay hope you enjoyed your chicken salad
because this has been swell thank
you so the sharp elbow somebody who's in
any way
vindictive is a deal breaker I would say
if someone is a
monologuer that's also deal breaker
right I I want somebody who is a good
listener good asker of
questions I think men tend to do this a
lot more than women the monologuing but
I've seen some
exceptions so I've dated some exceptions
yeah yeah moners over talkers people
who step on me or other people when
they're a midth thought to like
interject or one up that gets
exhausting so those be a few that come
to mind I mean I'm sure there are others
but those are a few that immediately
leap to mind when you ask well and part
of what you're describing is something
that the gotman Institute would
reinforce which is
that what are our implicit rules about
conflict and that the couples that have
staying
power tend to have
boundaries on no matter how upset I am
with you there are some places that I
don't go mhm because in a long-term
partnership you know each other so well
that you also have the capacity to
really hurt the other person yeah
totally because you know what would hurt
them and you secretly think it sometimes
especially when you're frustrated and
that even in those moments you don't go
somewhere that is
gratuitously that sharp elbow or
vindictiveness or or
meanness yeah you don't turn it into a
Quenton Tarantino action sequence right
it's not yeah and it's always amazing to
me that they're actually Kill Bill kill
exactly all of a sudden suddenly you
didn't know it but I was wearing that
you know yellow suit Su jumpsuit under
my pajamas tonight so I think that
the
boundaries that we each assume on how we
handle the hardest moments those being
shared boundaries feels
like a
wise sort of guideline to have for
yourself the other thing that I was
thinking about about your processing
point is that for me it feels like boy
there's a long period during which where
we're bumping into each other and where
there's some friction between
us processing it to understand it better
like what was going on with me that I
did interrupt you which by the way
interrupting is one of the things
I feedback I give my husband because
he's a big interruptor which makes me
crazy crazy and that means in part I'm
blaming him for this that I am an
interruptor because if I don't get my
word in edgewise I'm not going to get in
MH and I think as a woman and a
professional in some of the spaces I'm
in being willing to speak up to get into
the
conversation when there's a moment to do
so in many contexts served me pretty
well and in other contexts and other
relationships I'm doing to other people
exactly the thing that he does to me my
husband does to me that makes me
so want to kill him the Kill Bill comes
to mind so the question of understanding
gosh what's going on with me when does
it happen what's going with him when
does it happen that kind of processing
can be
helpful and then there's a point where
we've we've talked about it 100 times
we've dissected it 100 times we're back
doing the
thing that triggers the
reaction and it just
is it just is so there's a point where
you have to decide and for me the switch
is he's changed as much as he's going to
change or I've changed as much as I'm
going to be able to
change I do it maybe less often or he
does it less often I still do it
sometimes and misstep so if I assume
this person is not going to change can I
live with that can we each live with
that and if so then then it's easier to
have the let me just note you did that
thing
again oh you're right I
apologize we can talk about it later if
we need to and we can move
on because we don't need to reprocess
something that we have already processed
and we're at the limits of how much each
of us is going to be able to change
sometimes like in some
moments totally
and what occurred to me as you're
talking also is that people like to do
what they're good at so the big strong
guys like to go to the weight room the
flexy people like to go do
yoga The Debaters like to debate and the
people who are on some level good at say
emotional processing like to emotionally
process yes right so if that is part of
their identity
then you are signing up for that and I
think I somewhat knowingly somewhat
unknowingly probably signed up for that
and she is very very good at it I just
it was I think a
constitutional meaning personal
Constitution mismatch of sorts
constitutional issue yeah no yeah yeah
not talking about the Second Amendment
here relax everybody yeah yeah people
like to do what they're good at and I
need to be cautious about that too right
because my response to some of that
would often be to try to kind of put her
in a cattle shoot to get her into this
like logic puzzle where I knew I would
be better right and that's I try to
steer her into some Labyrinth of
spreadsheets and analytics because I'm
better at that stuff and that wasn't
helpful it was hugely counterproductive
I'm sure at many different points but
that's what I'm good at and so more and
more I've tried to cultivate an
awareness of what I do because I am good
at said thing whatever that is which
applies to so not just relationships but
also how you structure your day and your
week and choose your projects like are
you choosing these things because
they're truly the most important or are
you choosing these things because you
happen to have some skill and therefore
it's comfortable for you to do these
things I think about that a lot I just
want to make a observation about what
you just said which was so insightful
and where you feel comfortable and what
you're good at because for some people I
don't know purse I don't know if this
true of her but for some people part of
what makes them feel safe or secure or
to re or reassured in a relationship is
to rock the
boat I've had some relationships like
that and rocking the boat so that we
have something to process helps me feel
connected to you is redemonstration that
you care and that processing emotional
processing goes to a place that feels
comfortable to me and feels reassuring
to
me in that place if we go back to the
three positions which is just there's my
perspective which is obviously
correct then there's the other person's
perspective the second position
inside their story and their world and
why they think they're correct and then
either or both of us could step to the
third position what would a neutral
Observer say about what's going on and
what might help us get through this
she's in the place where like I want to
be connected with you we need to be
ourselves connecting in the first and
second position and the place where you
go because you feel more comfortable
might be the third position to step out
to be analytical about it to say well
let me just step back to understand
what's happening here cuz if I can
understand what's happening here I need
to know then I have advice for myself
about where to go and she's like don't
leave me here like you're you're
disconnecting to go to the balcony or
the third position yeah you should do
this for a living yeah
kidding so that's the way in which like
that processing also was not serving its
purpose for her and was like not where
you felt you wanted to be or or what she
was asking of you yeah that resonates as
very on point and I would further say
that I contributed to that
by for most of our relationship being
very weak in terms of her love language
of words of affirmation so it would make
sense to me
that with a
deficit of with a lack or a deficiency
of words of affirmation
that one could be male female doesn't
matter would want to rock the boat to
elicit yeah that type of connection in
processing to get those words of
affirmation so I think I almost
certainly contributed to that very
directly in that way yeah I have that
same profile that's a weakness for me
also and I see it showing up in my
personal relationships as well as my
work relationships giving words of
affirmation yeah my family was not a
super demonstrative family to feel the
need to say it out loud yeah same same
so how do you work on that I'm curious I
mean I have improved I'm still very much
on training wheels but I I have made
substantial Improvement I think how are
you working on it or how have you found
it what have you found helpful to work
on giving words of affirmation positive
reinforcement because I I did not grow
up with a whole lot of that and very
much learned to do without it in say
sports as well and in skill development
kind of trained myself not to really
require it and to be intrinsically
motivated so I
then expect that
of most people which is an unfair
expectation it just doesn't map to
reality very well so how have you worked
on it some of it is just with
conscious reminders to
myself to do it like a timer and on your
phone and index card with five lines
that you can pull out and be like hold
on
John no I'm kidding well you're kidding
the kind of thing I might do honest to
God yeah I mean and it's also trying to
get better at noticing in myself when I
do feel grateful for something somebody
did like I get an email that I'm just
like oh my God that is so helpful just
to remember to say it out loud yeah to
just shoot them back in note to say like
thank you so much for taking the time it
took to
send this to me because it's incredibly
helpful and that's all it needs to be I
also noticed that I'm better at it in
writing than I am
verbally so that's okay that's where the
training wheels are to remember just
text to say when I notice something
specific that's something we didn't talk
about about appreciation which is to
seem genuine like great job isn't very
genuine compelling yeah compelling
doesn't sound necessarily sincere being
specific helps so also just like hey I
particularly appreciated your note or I
thought your whatever was
particularly had a really big impact on
me I I think the more I can just notice
the small things that are specific the
better and that's helped me I don't know
do you have other tips because I could
use them so I was exaggerating a bit
with the index card but for a while and
I could probably use
with doing more of this I would
literally put in a calendar
reminder yeah just like say something
nice to this person this person this
person yeah yeah and there's always
something I can think of that is
specific and I just for
whatever
malfunction or being little nicer to
myself conditioning through my
upbringing neglected to mention than I
would mention I literally put it in my
calendar yeah and I I found that helpful
I did find it helpful well and I also am
am appreciating I'll say it right now
I'm
appreciating you're connecting this to
maybe what was going on that caused the
hey we need processing I need
reassurance because I'm not sure where I
stand or I felt overlooked or not seen
Etc
which part of what I'm learning is that
when I have somebody who is frustrated
or upset it is often that they are also
feeling
underappreciated and that's on me
totally so let me ask
you a bit
about giving feedback instead of
receiving and I know we've we've touched
on this indirectly and and maybe even
directly in this
conversation but for people who are in
the supervisor boss
or it could be significant other but we
we spent a bunch of time on the personal
let's talk about the professional even
though they're sure two sides of the
same
[Music]
coin if you are giving feedback to
someone who tends to be sensitive I'll
just set the Stag this not actually
really the case for me right now in any
capacity but it has been at various
points with employees with significant
others what are your suggestions for
giving Fe back
mhm and how to open that door hopefully
in a way that
doesn't immediately provoke or
exacerbate a really defensive type of
Kickback yeah one Foundation thing is
have the two of you had a conversation
about how they prefer to get
feedback and that can be one of the most
helpful and powerful things to do which
is to sit down and talk about hey what
what makes you feel appreciated because
some people need to hear the words other
people don't really care about the words
but the fact that you come to them for
advice with some of your toughest
problems or you you know would like
their input on your proof reading tells
them they're valued right so what makes
you feel appreciated if I have coaching
for
you what's your advice to me on when and
how to give it do you have pet peeves
about feedback generally we all have pet
peeves that's a really interesting
conversation to
have when you're triggered by
feedback how can I tell how will I be
able to tell and
um might be totally obvious but
sometimes people shut down and I can't
tell whether you're taking it in or
arguing in your
head and when you are triggered or
feeling defensive what advice do you
have for me on what will help and we
have a we have a little template that's
like how to get the best out of
me that each of us can jot down some
thoughts too and then talk about how to
get the best out of me is that a
template that is available online or
that we could put in the show notes yeah
on the Triad Consulting website Triad
Consulting
group.com we have a a nav called help
yourself and it's got a bunch
of templates exercises
Etc Great so we'll link to that
just having that conversation up front
means I don't have to guess at how to
give you feedback because you've already
told me and hopefully I've taken some
notes which I keep hand to remind
myself and so I can refer back like hey
I had a couple of thoughts about the
presentation last week and I wonder when
it would be helpful to chat about it a
little bit or whatever
right the second thing is that really
the fastest way to change a feedback
culture and to help people be more
receptive is to become a good receiver
yourself and be soliciting and eliciting
feedback from others and to assume every
conversation
even when I think I'm pretty clearly The
Giver here I'm probably going to end up
being a receiver because what they're
going to say is well the reason I did
that is because you were so unclear
about what you wanted or whatever so I
have to assume there are things I've
contributed to the situation that are
going to be part of the conversation
even when for me the primary purpose is
to tell you what I think you could do
differently or
better there's a question that we use a
lot
that I think is incredibly helpful just
in building a habit of integrating
feedback into daily life which is not
hey do you have any feedback for me
which we've talked about is a terrible
question well- intended but
terrible particularly from a leader
because giving feedback up feels very
risky and fraught so if you are in a
position of
leadership you are impacting more and
more people and fewer and fewer of them
are take the chance to tell you about it
so you've got to actually have some
pretty Advanced skills in receiving
feedback and inviting it and one way you
can do that is to ask what's one thing
what's one thing that I'm doing or maybe
failing to do that you think is getting
in the way or what's one thing that if I
could change it would make a difference
to you or what's one thing that in our
Monday morning meeting we could change
to make it more efficient because I know
people are flagging their energy
flagging that's a question that you can
toss off while you're walking down the
hall and lowers the stakes it's very
clear you're asking for coaching you're
looking for something to improve and
you're also signaling and by the way I
expect you to be receptive to coaching
also because I'm going to demonstrate I
value it I assume I'm still learning and
I expect that you're still learning too
one thing one thing what's one thing
funny how one thing at a time put in
sequence how much that can do is that is
there anything because if you ask is
there anything people like Oh no you're
great we love working with you yeah
that's kind of like my if you had to cut
20% what would you cut yeah that's one
of the reasons that's such a great
question it applies some very clear
constraints constraints right they like
the option of not naming something is
not implicit in that question that's
fair that's fair yeah do you get people
who ignore the question anyway no
because they make terrible proof readers
and so
generally
my friends know ex I mean these are
people I've known for a while typically
so they know they know exactly what
they're signing up for and they know
what type of feedback I have given them
in the past right also so it's
reciprocal oh yeah yeah yeah yeah for
sure so they have a very good idea
of exactly what I'm looking for and
they'll ask clarifying questions if need
be but what is one thing dot dot dot is
a really useful heuristic for getting
the type of feedback but that may not be
forthcoming especially if you are MH at
the top of the pyramid or in the
hierarchy in a leadership
position well Sheila we've covered a lot
what have we not covered is there
anything that you would like to discuss
before we begin to whine to a close if
we neglected
anything that pops to mind we've
certainly gone through a lot of
different scenarios we've gone through
the interpersonal we've gone through
intimate relationships we've gone
through professional environments is
there any particular point that comes to
mind or anything you'd like
to to add before we begin to land the
plane what's in my head is maybe a
follow on to what you just said about
the one thing and being in leadership so
when we were working on the feedback
book part of the challenge is that the
need to give feedback is a felt problem
like I have feedback for you I'm
carrying it around with myself because I
don't know how to give it to you or I've
tried to give it to you and you're not
taking it so if there's a book that
would help me do that I would buy that
book and could use some help the need to
receive
feedback from other people who are
carrying it around and not giving it to
us is not necessarily A felt
problem I'm oblivious to it I have mixed
feelings about it it's like carbon
monoxide yes the Invisible Killer that's
right it is the Invisible Killer that's
actually a very good metaphor for
it so do I want a carbon monoxide
detector I do I know I should you do and
it's also moving from a push model of
learning I decide what you need to learn
and I push you to learn it to a pull
model of learning which is I'm curious
what you think I have to learn or could
improve which is very much your stance
Tim it's very relaxing to be with
someone who has that stance right yeah
it's also and I think your book does a
great job of this I mean it is a
learnable skill right I learned this
through skill acquisition where for
instance I would need to have to
turn lay people non coaches into coaches
right and to do that you have to elicit
with lots of very specific questions and
very wellth thought through questions
for instance if you want a native
speaker to help you learn your target
language that is actually a very big ask
and very challenging if they are not
trained teachers yes right if you go up
to a native English speaker and you're
like tell me the difference between
anything and something or like when do
you use n versus the' when it's a new
person being introduced to a sense like
there's most native English speakers
would fail the test of English as a
foreign language or do very poorly it
would be so confusing because what is
reflexive is not something they can
explain and so I think I've developed
that
stance through a lot of repetitions with
mostly different
skills and it is not something that came
intuitively but it is something that you
can pick up very very quickly with the
right toolkit and with that
toolkit you become an incredibly skilled
and fast learner and I think that's a
big aha for me which is oh gosh I can
learn from anybody they don't have to be
a skilled Giver because I can help with
that to hear and understand what they're
trying to tell me and then I can figure
out what to make of it and what I want
to take away and leave behind the last
thing on this front is that as Leaders
sometimes people will say well I don't
really know what I should be working
on and you know my answer to them is
like well you know who knows pretty much
everybody else everybody around you has
a
list of the things you do that make it
harder for them to do their
job and it's a list they pass amongst
each other about you so it becomes the
sort of conventional wisdom about you
what's great about you and what's hard
about working with you but if you want
to know what on that list you have to
ask and you have to ask in a way that
persuades them that you actually want to
know and you'll take it seriously you
can't promise that you can change it or
you would change it but at
least listening for the themes that you
hear from different people at different
times will help identify the things that
oh yeah that's probably something that's
not helping in this context yeah and
this topic of feedback right thanks for
the feedback the science and art of
receiving feedback well
is it's a bit of a trojan horse for a
bunch of things as you mentioned right
if you want to be a super learner it
doesn't just apply to interacting with
your boss at work it doesn't just apply
to your direct reports at work it
doesn't just apply to your significant
other actually applies in a million
different
contexts how can you elicit the feedback
that will most help you to take
constructive next steps I mean it
applies to everything to that extent I
mean it's very much a meta skill
that is transferable across a million
different disciplines yeah Sheila people
can find the Triad Consulting Group at
Tri Consulting group.com and I also did
go to the help yourself you have all
sorts of
tools and links available on the help
yourself portion of that website so
people can go there is there any
anywhere else you would like to point
people well so I've been trying to get
better at social media and Linkedin so
we triy has a LinkedIn page and I now
have a LinkedIn page and I try to
post
occasionally and get more than
occasionally so I think that the
question of where do I get help with
this we also have a list of what's on
our Shelf right you do too Tim we have a
lot of overlap in the kinds of things
that
you're reading and thinking about
and this journey is such a central one
that there's lots of different resources
out there I'll double check to see if
our latest list of resources things that
we would recommend is up great so we'll
Link in the show notes then to certainly
thanks for the feedback the book and
books PR Consulting Group and then to
the respective LinkedIn Pages for people
who would like to explore and we'll put
those a tim. Blog podcast as per usual
any last words before we before we go
I'll say thank you very much for the
time as always have enjoyed the
conversation immensely and taking
copious notes yeah I am thinking about
your dating
project yeah and journey I'll be
interested to hear how it goes
and also what you find that cuts to the
heart of what do what do I want to
understand about this person and about
myself MH in the way that we show up
together that is either super energizing
and rewarding and fun which is how it
should
be or anxiety-provoking and
draining yes I would strongly prefer to
lean heavily in the former grouping
instead of the lad so I will I'll keep
you posted on my progress in that
department perfect thank you so much for
taking the time thank you always such a
pleasure and to everybody listening
you've heard this before until next time
be just a bit Kinder than is necessary
not only to others but to yourself know
thyself as the sign would say over the
Oracle at Deli part of that is learning
how to elicit and metabolize good
feedback so take a close look at it and
until next time thanks for tuning
in